Представляти Росію буде не Максим Галкин.
Або іще варіант - і не Євгеній Петросян.
А так, щоб ви знали про всяк випадок, представляти Росію буде Путін.
Так після оголошення результатів екзит-полів Петро Порошенко, звертаючись до молоді,
намагався жартувати про недосвідченість свого конкурента -
лідера першого туру президентських перегонів Володимира Зеленського.
Але насправді самому Порошенку, судячи з усього, не до сміху.
П'ять років тому він переміг на президентських виборах
у першому ж турі з результатом у майже 55 відсотків голосів.
А нині з провальною різницею програє шоумену Зеленському.
Такий результат був цілком очікуваним,
адже розчарування політикою чинного гаранта в Україні - надто велике.
За свою каденцію Порошенко втілив далеко не всі реформи, які обіцяв.
Перелічувати їх можна довго: це і незадовільна боротьба з корупцією,
і провалена судова реформа, і домовленості з українськими олігархами,
і незавершена війна на Донбасі.
Проте головне - українці не задоволені рівнем життя, який залишається одним з найнижчих у Європі,
і покладають провину за це саме на Порошенка.
Результатом протестного голосування українців, власне, й став успіх Володимира Зеленського.
Я хочу подякувати нашим всім українцям, які голосували "не по приколу".
Багато українців, особливо молодь,
сприймають Зеленського як нове обличчя на політичній арені України
на противагу представникам старого покоління,
в тому числі і Юлії Тимошенко.
І хоча успіх Зеленського завадив її планам на президентство,
і кандидатка вибула з боротьби за президентське крісло після першого туру,
це не означає, що на політичній кар’єрі Тимошенко поставлено крапку, зауважують оглядачі.
Не виключено, що у неї є "план Б" - підтримати Зеленського у другому турі
в обмін на створення їхніми політсилами коаліції після парламентських виборів.
За словами позафракційного народного депутата Мустафи Наєма,
це, фактично, означало б, що Зеленський оголосить Тимошенко прем’єр-міністром.
Утім, і Зеленський, і Тимошенко такі домовленості заперечують.
Шоумен заявив, що йому, мовляв, нема про що говорити зі старою владою.
Тоді як сама Тимошенко публічно відмовилася визнавати дані екзитполів
і все ще розраховує на те, що
після підведення реальних результатів виборів,
зібрання оригіналів протоколів ми будемо боротися з Володимиром Зеленським у другому турі.
Саме у другому турі перед українцями стоятиме найскладніший вибір.
Їм доведеться обирати між чинним президентом,
якого переважна більшість з них вже не хоче, та його опонентом -
коміком, про чиї політичні цілі українці можуть лише здогадуватися.
Поки що "заслуга" Зеленського лише в тому,
що у серіалі "Слуга народу" він виконав роль непідкупного і принципового президента,
якого українці, вочевидь, і хотіли б бачити очільником держави в реальності.
Однак політична програма шоумена доволі розпливчаста,
на зустрічі з представниками ЄС він не зміг дати чіткої відповіді на жодне з питань,
а у своїй передвиборчій кампанії Зеленський залишався насамперед коміком, а не політиком.
Тож, як пишуть європейські ЗМІ, українцям з таким вибором не позаздриш.